[Música]
como lo adelantábamos europa vuelve al
epicentro en la pandemia de cubit 19
según la organización mundial de la
salud el ritmo actual de transmisión del
coronavirus en ese continente es muy
preocupante y podría provocar medio
millón de muertos adicionales de aquí
hasta febrero 2022 el director de la o
ms europa hanks look insistió en la
necesidad de actuar de forma proactiva y
defendió reimplantar medidas sociales y
de salud pública la región europea de la
oms que incluye a 53 países de europa y
asia central registró en sólo una semana
casi
1.8 millones nuevos casos y 24 mil
muertes por covite 19 quiero saludar
entonces a nuestro segundo invitado del
día el es daniel lópez acuña
epidemiólogo y ex director de acción
sanitaria de la organización mundial de
la salud danielle gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo américa porque
europa es el nuevo epicentro de esta
pandemia en el mundo
buenos días sí mira el yo creo que es
importante entender cómo se está
comportando en estos momentos bajan del
mismo europa la situación europa no es
uniforme hay situaciones extremas de mi
vida la incidencia como en los países
bálticos como en el reino unido y como
en este en europa y países con españa
que mantiene la incidencia por fortuna
todavía de alrededor de 50 por 100.000
habitantes siempre considerar un riesgo
intermedio y bajo y esto obedece a
distintos factores que están influyendo
sobre esta realidad pero en cualquier
caso la alerta que fue manifestada por
hans club que es muy muy adecuada ya que
tenemos que tomar en cuenta que esto no
puede simplemente verse como un fenómeno
natural que evolucione ante el que no se
responda la situación que hoy tenemos es
que la combinación de
relajación temprana de medidas
restrictivas y de protección y la baja
vacunación nos están dando estas
situaciones de altísimas en el reino
unido según el género
desde mi punto de vista de decretar el
filón del mejor de julio con una
incidencia muy alta y lamentablemente
las autoridades centrales no han
entendido a pesar de lo que ha señalado
por el cuerpo profesional de medicina y
salud pública en un reino unido que no
se puede hacer así las cosas que había
que volver marcha atrás por algunas de
las restricciones que no podía quitarse
la obligatoriedad de la mascarilla en el
en un gen interior es más destilados el
y como consecuencia tenemos una
incidencia de 800 por 100.000 habitantes
una gran presión asistencial y un número
muy elevado
tenemos en otros países como los países
bálticos y es una situación parecida a
la que tenemos en rumanía bulgaria en
donde hay muy baja tasa de vacunas eso
le quería preguntar doctor porque esta
baja tasa de vacunación porque la gente
está reacia a vacunarse todavía hay
muchas personas en la región europea que
no creen en las vacunas o la falta de
acceso efe pues falta de mejores
políticas para esta vacunación a su
opinión que es lo que está ocurriendo
entonces con esta vacunación contra el
coito
bueno es es una combinación de factores
que tienen que ver con lo que acaba
ustedes leen suna
y si tomamos el caso de países como
alemania o como bulgaria son países que
han tenido acceso a dosis de vacunas
pero no están teniendo la capacidad de
los sistemas sanitarios para poder
aplicar la vacuna a toda la población no
es que tengamos un 60 o 70 por ciento de
la población que rechaza la vacuna sino
que hay una ineficacia en el sistema
sanitario pero en países como alemania o
francia u otros países de la europa
central
lo que tenemos es una presencia muy alta
del movimiento anti vacunas del
negacionismo y de la reticencia a hacer
vacuna mientras que si vamos a un país
como españa que ha logrado vacunar al 90
por ciento de su población diana lo que
tenemos es una situación donde hay una
confianza de la población en el sistema
sanitario y una conducta de la población
que no es reticente a hacer vacunas
algunos países como el reino unido-
conocieron también el error
no completar la pauta de vacunación de
querer expandir sobre la primera dosis y
no la suficiente velocidad para
completar la segunda por eso también
vemos parte del problema que estamos
viendo ahora entonces era una
combinación de factores pero no hay duda
si la resistencia a ser vacunado existe
en muchos países de europa y es
lamentable hay que trabajar con ella y
por otro lado hay que reforzar los
mecanismos para poder
ahora doctor con la llegada de la
temporada fría la temporada de invierno
en europa podemos ver un aumento
exponencial de los casos de kobe 19 una
población tienen en cuenta todo lo que
ya hablamos anteriormente
la temporada otoño invernal supone un
riesgo incrementado para varias
enfermedades respiratorias antes una es
el coni pero no la vamos a preocupar es
la gripe estacional e incluso las
infecciones por vías respiratorias
necesidades la realidad es que el en
este otoño-invierno estamos viendo un
reporte de casos en muchos países y es
la suma de factores el otoño/invierno la
insuficiente válvula ción y la
relajación prematura e inadecuada de
medidas de protección y la restricción
en estos momentos yo creo que todos los
precios tienen que considerar y tiene y
estará empezando a hacerlo y tienen que
volver a implantar el uso obligatorio de
la mascarilla a ventilar los espacios a
establecer límites de aforos en espacios
interiores mal ventilados ya analizar
todo lo que pueden intensificar la
vacunación incluida la
doctor rápidamente ya para finalizar
nuestra conversación vemos esto en
europa podemos esperar algo similar en
nuestra región en américa latina'
si lo que estamos viendo en estos
momentos en europa se puede repetir en
otras regiones incluirán gelatina
recordemos primero que la vacuna no es
esterilizante una protegía de la
seguridad y del riesgo de muerte de
riesgo de hospitalización te surgen
nuevas variantes en la medida en que
sigamos teniendo altas incidencias en el
mundo entero vamos a tener sus 500
nuevas variantes y bananas brindando
amenazantes y en la medida en que en su
momento entremos en situaciones
climáticas como las de boston invierno
en europa es profunda del hemisferio del
américa latina pues podemos tener un
riesgo incrementado de
contagios y poder objetar una nueva